welcome to this video playing card start
and you ever met i forgot the name of
the sky i played him a couple of times
no okay yep go for the news oh let's see
five pilots a bit out of fashion okay
role of wonder what was the point that
okay now i usually go for this setup
here trying to put some pressure on the
d file cancelling that's very simple
play but usually enough to retain a
slight advantage i think i actually had
this against this player before I'm
reasonably sure okay I'm Bishop here to
look at t6
hmm
you
I a night to you for hmm that looks a
little bit like history repeating like I
had this before okay and I have to do
this all 94 I can take 90 x Group D for
still feels a little bit better for
wider wow what okay that was a very
quick decision and the very it's a very
I mean it's a very responsible decision
just give up I'm going to this material
with material imbalance it's quite
surprising am Bishop d3 was actually
interesting I was only thinking that ok
well this end game is great for me yes
this is why I didn't look much further
but I should have maybe should have done
so so um yeah go here I mean Bishop a
594 drops d 6 which is the problem
anyway I wonder if there's even
something better takes 94 takes it takes
d5 is probably probably the point
well i think i should just gained a
little bit of space there and make sure
i'm not mated 94 is not something
exclusive for this particular move i
mean i can always do that texting hmm
and i think this is better I mean d5 I
can take take a6 that's technically very
nice and I have the time here okay um
9292 for Bishop f.3d five if he goes d5
I mean I take take Bishop f3 and wind
stuff mindsets that's almost technical
windows position I think wow what is he
doing rooty three no I hope this Roxy to
actually then looked e3 e4 nine ticks
can I threaten this somehow I don't know
I mean if it takes light c4 is still
very good maybe has looks you own or
something d for I've night f-14 also
okay it's okay it's not as grade em it's
not as grade now maybe that was a more
precise move than 92 to prevent e5 the
immediate d5
I fight is still very much better I was
just thinking it should be a very easy
win but this doesn't look that easy at
least relatively speaking i was really
thinking it's a totally trivial and i
don't think it is probably take them and
then you will take with the porn i guess
I can go look this three year when our
group t8 is no threat unfortunately
93 95 maybe
Bishop g5 though ok
how to do that maybe maybe like Bishop
d3 845 it might be an idea I mean I've
got not badly coordinated actually it's
not not that bad everything's kind of
protected the polymer endpoints are safe
and this at least seems to establish
this night is very very strong only for
if he has to move in G porn like can't
do this now switch to the two here can I
get rid of that rook rook is really
annoying King III f3 Bishop around or
something maybe check
okay I've seen some ID a.m. to try to
grab the initiative with rupee seven it
looks good
hmm it looks yeah so check here on the
bishop is hanging there amazing is there
something else that I can do here and
probably not go back nice Lucas hanging
all the time should take it sometime
check check check check black forfeits
on time pretty nervous end to that game
yeah I really think that that this he
went very quickly to this transformation
and I think black is really in terrible
shape after that is really amazing it
wasn't necessary at all I mean he can
play whatever yeah maybe even a five is
playable but you can definitely I just
move the night or queen c6 or whatever
this is just just just absolutely awful
for black
yeah I went here I mean what I wasn't
sure maybe here I could have done that
that's it's possible well maybe that was
even better to totally force this thing
but I was thinking this is a good way to
play yeah here here i can't improve
definitely i went 92 and didn't cd5
coming which made things a little bit
more difficult the problem is here and
he has just frozen his pawn structure in
the center and killed his own bishop so
I have to do something I wanted to do to
do something like this yeah dominate him
here I just played the wrong move order
this is much much better because he d 5
is not working and I had the similar
idea in mind when I went here i was
thinking route d5 bishop f3 yeah that's
nice but he has this movie and then e
for this is irritating the engine gives
this which i saw i thought that this is
probably not that bad but i wasn't
wasn't totally convinced this is given
as a win by the comp yeah probably the
deep one is too quick but ok this wasn't
bad i mean it just keeps things as is
and what is katie better No thank you
I'm gonna always keep some kind of
advantage we didn't have much time can
ya the clock time somehow I'm not shown
I don't know yeah here it was a really
nervous nervous kind of game Bishop a
tree was a bit better him but when the
winners win okay well thanks for
watching